welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz and today
I am joined by Alicia Tegel who is one
of the cofounders of sr2 recruitment and
who is an all-round legend apparently
thank you so much for joining me today
thank you I know obviously you've been
meeting clients and everything but
you're from Bristol
I am indeed proud to come inside to do a
podcast to look big thank you and look
where I am always love to start let's go
back to the story as to how Alicia Tegel
got into recruitment
how did that happen let's start there
Alan Sugar do you know what my story is
so similar to yours no I did two seasons
and I Napper oh god yeah yeah you can
make killin as a Connie Lee an absolute
killer yeah amazing and best two summers
I actually got swine flu my last season
really what a lot to come out and get me
yeah yeah really bad
what did you pick lineup what did you
like go to there on holiday year before
no it was just always actually supposed
to be going to Cyprus with my
ex-boyfriend yeah yeah and say that was
all booked got a suitcase for my
birthday and tickets are inside then we
split up a couple of months before the
girls were going out to I enough but I
thought I could just change my flights
we're already going to side roads go to
Anna you stayed out there and I stayed
out there unless you went from going to
on a couples holiday yeah to do a season
and I thought yeah four months at four
months each and then when I got back I
joined an insurance company really yeah
Liv prove it to her LV did sales like
two years actually loved it and then
sort of got the phone phobia and yeah I
just needed to do something more so I
moved into a sales trainer yeah roll
with ovios with LV for about four and a
half years oh really
yeah and then from LV I decided you want
my time was up there moved
- RAC over there sells trainers senior
sales trainers and sorry Ric I just
didn't like your culture and buffered me
some of the ways of working but
hopefully it's changed and I was there
for eight months and during that eight
months I had seen some recruitment
things going on and I was like sure like
if do you do you have any exposure with
agencies at that point we used to do a
lot of LV no nothing I did when
everything director I never I don't
think I'd ever been for an agent okay
and then anyway yeah mm sir Ric saw some
recruitment things and you know you get
sucked in by the money or you can make a
hundred grand a year and then I thought
yeah let's give it give it a go with
making really good money LV on the phone
as a trainer then going from I I think I
was maybe on about 35 brandy a base as
well sales trainer just seeing something
that 17 grand I was like oh my god of
all my thinking but you know what like
let's give it a go and and when I
started when I fought on gave equipment
I found all the Georgia erector I can
Bristol and got contacted by max max
like right we're gonna send you to all
of these companies and I saw such faces
andwe went in I think I interviewed
eight places I got not been here did I
got offered all eight and I chose a very
small company of four people to join
biggest mistake I've ever made
actually that's a complete lie it's not
the biggest thing it was a it led me to
a lot of things so it was a blessing in
disguise
so joined everybody small company called
stream I thought yeah for people they
can teach me everything I know I would
the owners next to me it was awful awful
awful and then as soon as I joined
obviously learned about LinkedIn put on
LinkedIn that I was here Chris who's my
business partner and I'm Dave SR to
message me and said why have you joined
there you need to come and speak to me
whether your friends I know that you're
not really friends of friends okay nice
we just saw that you went there on
LinkedIn and he was Audion recruitment
yes he knew the market yeah so he was
already done Opus he was then a trans
dad a Sales Director for Bristol
and he messaged me he was three weeks
into the role and yeah when I met him on
it's funny story actually went and met
him after work and yeah he told me all
about man said like oh my god I've made
a really bad decision I'm not going to
do it means that you are this is how I'm
I'm good and make you amazing sold me
the dream loss that I can he's like you
need to come back
meet my meet Mike he's the MD of ever at
Tech tomorrow and lunch I'll meet you
here and I said okay so went for lunch
and I'm sat in the restaurant and the
owner
I'm only red because I'm like pushing 30
and I think I'm having a midlife crisis
yeah so I walk back into the office
after get an offer and I was like I'm
gonna join you and I said I'm leaving he
was like yeah I guessed up I'm not
paying you I said well you do need to
paint me because I've been there at like
three weeks and I got the money join
Ron's dad I was Chris's first hire and
we had an absolute ball for three years
yeah yeah
this race is a very quickly it was
always like to ask
so before you so did you like research
for cream and then basically love work
did you have a perception of recruitment
before you started looking into or not
really no but I didn't know it no one
that I knew was in recruitment yeah
you're bad for it's just money
yeah just money and thinking oh yeah
let's just give this a go I had no idea
what in doubt no man no I knew I was
good at sells yeah well I done in the
past but nothing I just felt I'm one of
those people that will just try
something yeah awesome
yeah how old is you at that point when
you have to take a pay cut 23 really say
yeah dad yeah so that cuz like what did
you have to take that 10k more pay car
yeah I went from 35 grand 17 grand
really yeah that's all so yeah and I was
like [ __ ]
well they done
like and ever they tell you this is the
pay cut that you're gonna do do this do
this do this so I knew that straightaway
I was gonna be skinned and I needed to
make some serious money so I needed to
work and I'm not afraid to fight so I
just got on with it so very quickly like
just but just before we dive into the
trance dance a trance that three and a
half years okay cool so they don't have
to be super personal but like why was
that first place not great because I
think people couldn't learn from that
right what did you learn
might be listening to this to a
considerable criminal may end up in the
company they're like I'll [ __ ] what have
I done
like what were some of the things that
you recognized after you'd met them
interview stuff like that do you not I
mean yeah for things that you realize
from the small company yeah I completely
agree like I've said this to the girls
that I've hired who said I don't want to
do recruitment again I've joined this
place isn't right for me I never wonder
again I'm like no come on and I joined a
small company thinking that they were
going to be able to give me all their
time and invest everything into me and
sitting next to the owner of the
business that's why I joined the company
I bit yeah so it would be a great thing
and to be honest the owner used to sit
in the coffee shop outside and look up
at us of wave and on our first my first
hour
he said call this person and I said okay
but what do I say
and he was like just go with it and I
was like yeah but I have no idea about
this company I don't know what I'm
saying I don't even know what Java is
yeah like how am I like I can't wing it
that much yeah I can wing something but
not being power into a brand new
industry a brand new role all surrounded
by all blokes in the only female and
just going oh [ __ ] I can't do this
so straightaway I was on the back foot
thinking I'm not doing this I feel so
uncomfortable yeah so would so okay so
but in the interview process they're
like looking back was there any key
things that people could look out
forward you know I mean they sold me the
dream really yeah they sold me the dream
of small company this what you're gonna
get this is the support which you can
always people can do and do an interview
everyone to people so the
the to choose well the main main main
cheese yeah difficult isn't yeah and it
was it was me probably being gullible
and also the right track and sorry I'm
actively do listen don't work with
companies that aren't gonna be right for
someone as well like get to know your
candidate whether now as a creature and
understand what their motivations are or
or their pipe of personality and put
them in places where they're going to
thrive rather than just hoping that
you're gonna get I mean let that happen
so much which is why as you said you've
now hired people that ended up going
into a recruitment company that is so
far aligned with who they are then
they're their perceptional recruitment
is is just shy it like you know nothing
nothing is a make sure of that isn't
it's a mixture of people have really bad
experiences in recruitments then they
get spouts of the industry and then they
don't like using recruiters yeah and
then you have businesses that then deal
with ship recruiters as well do you not
mean okay so a transfer for over three
years that's a totally different ball
game isn't it they're they're a huge
company so how big was your team when
you joined the dish you and Chris no
that was about so Chris was brought in
because it wasn't doing well the
technology brand so around still don't
see the huge visa if their technology
brand was one in London and one in
Bristow and it was it just wasn't doing
well so Chris has been brought in to
revamp it I'm special everyone had been
there for like six six years and there
was two guys who'd been there for
experience but only a couple of months
so there was about seven eight of us in
Bristol and there was about twenty in
London because he was part of this big
beast but it didn't feel like it yeah
exactly
and I trusted Chris I he changed my life
and he taught me everything that I knew
but with Randstad yes it's a smaller
company but you the training you go away
for a week in Luton the best training a
trainer is sat next to my first sales
call she was sat next to me going right
this is busy for the guy exactly
so I think it's all the support and it
is the same as the s3 since the haze
it's the wrong you can't fall how they
produce in development and then the
industry when Tim was Tech from day one
yeah check from day one software
development software development yeah ok
cool so let's talk about how are you
first 12 months and always like to dive
into that and like I did really well
really yeah I did my first delve in 3
weeks which was really random because I
printed off back and day I used to print
off CVS I don't know ever everyone used
to do that and I just used have folders
and I used to write on CBS I'm such a
tree killer really yeah I don't know why
I just used to print off TVs every CV
write notes on them and then put them in
folders I don't know it was my wave work
and it worked is weird
everyone told me not told me off that
said stop [ __ ] printing on TV to do
that now I don't even know where CDs I
like somewhere in the cloud yeah but
yeah in terms of I printed off the CV
and then Chris was that next to me said
this guy's perfect for that where have
you found him and I said I'd got a CV on
a piece of paper of all my notes and he
said send him to him here did I'd give
my first day off in three weeks and I
was like amazing I'm good but then I
didn't do a deal for four months for
four months yeah I had three offers
accepted and then and then turned around
and I could remember the third one I
branstad we had like a fire exit and
then somewhere that you looked over and
there was a nightclub underneath and
lots of smoking area and I said I'm
going I'm jumping off so many such drama
queens I
okay calm down and then I smashed out
140 grand in the first year in the first
year yes so so yes you did 140 k over
really what a yeah and well loads a star
for me more like newcomer of the year
wonderful and then yeah and it just
spray that bad enough you get a lot of
value out of that so I think it's one of
those isn't it like when you do get when
you get the deal so quickly it's also a
bit of light it can also damage you a
bit because Elias is easy but you know I
mean but let's talk about those because
a lot of people would probably quit in
those four months you know I mean that
you had because lie again there's not
like the fact that you still remember
the exact you pretty remember exactly
how you felt as well yeah I mean that's
obviously it's so difficult to write
those ways of blanking and and having
those fall outs and those things so I
guess what what did you learn through
those four months if you think about
like what would it what kept me fruit
kept kept picking yourself back up and
those things like how did you get free
that I think I'm gonna go back to him
again but Chris has been my support okay
cool and also the team I was always the
only female in round seven nine months
and I was surrounded by men who
literally lifted me up and supported me
really and made me feel and there were
all different ages from my age to Johnny
was what probably I don't want to say
were all willing to give up their time
and it didn't matter like if they were
gonna see me succeed I was first in the
office laugh yeah I knew I was doing
something right because I was getting
office but they just weren't going in
for some reason so it's a training thing
that I wasn't maybe qualifying them
enough and things like that but I always
say the biggest thing in recruitment no
matter what is resilient it's like a
muscle that is the biggest thing and I
say that to AP's here for when I'm when
I've been asked about it a number of
times you've got be resilient and you go
watch tomorrow's a new day because
otherwise you will quit because this job
can be the shittest job whole world or
it could be the best job in the whole
wide world so I think it's also I think
well if you are experiencing a couple of
bad months right it's like okay well
who-who can I speak to around whose
experience that can help me understand
why this is happening
yeah is it part of the process those
things I think I definitely experienced
the same thing it took me three or so
months so now I had a couple of offers
these things and my boss always remember
you kept saying like he shouldn't keep
didn't we do it it's like that it's the
right it is gonna pay off do you know I
mean yeah obviously I only ended up
building 24k he kept saying like he
should he didn't we didn't blow a lot so
I think what you're talking about there
is when you are having those really
difficult months it's like especially
when you're early on in your career is
what actually this is this is the long
this is a long term play yeah so I think
it's just about trying to very quickly
caught veyts in perspective isn't it and
go okay well what can I learn from this
like my recruitment query is long gonna
be longer than four months so what can I
learn from this and then do better next
time yeah okay that's really cool so I
guess what did you would you another one
differently then to build that much by
the end of year ones you know I mean
what what wounded up war changed my the
first deal I did was like a really
random role maybe like an Android dev
for example and I think that happens a
lot in recruitment when someone new
comes in and we always say with the
newbies that we've got and new visa came
in to run said we sometimes the
experienced person just give them a job
this exclusive work on that and fill it
it's not gonna be in your market but
yeah you're on your way then because of
confidence yeah exactly
and it was a really random role and then
I literally learn the ins and outs of
Java like really everything I could from
the candidates all the companies like
just did the basics really well and I
was just relentless and I just kept
going and kept doing the same thing I
had a day planner
every single day knows only one who had
a day planner in the whole earth and I
just went and I just did did that I did
the basic free well and I broke it down
and just went for it but understanding
your market it's so easily to get
sidetracked say for example if you win a
big client and there's so many different
roles in your life who money
but as soon as you're working and
network engineer first line support a
third line support Java developer
c-sharp and iOS dev like that's where it
all goes wrong stick to one thing that
you're really good at and find out
everything about know the ins and outs
and that's when people were little
people early on then how so you said you
were relentless but how did you go about
doing that obviously a lot people say
for the candidates right so literally
shut up and listen and speak to your
candidates and find out about the market
right through them and then in your own
time as well actually really research
the industry the people the businesses
as well and as I said super lucky to be
surrounded by people who were like 10
years into recruitment who knew what
they were talking about like I wasn't
around people who didn't know who were
just trying to trying to black it like
they knew what they were on about and
I'm I'm quite interested in technology
as well myself
oh really yeah so I'm not a developer
I've tried to code I'm all for it and
I'm never doing it again but it does
excite me and I do get so yeah ask
questions be open and just be like a
human being and like they want to tell
you about themselves let them tell you
by ask open questions don't show it down
and just yeah and just be friends with
them make friends be killed be cool yeah
and and get to know them and they'll
respect you enough to open up yeah
so very quickly then before we talk
about the things that went on after
light I'll get a lot of questions that
people want a voice or help with like
beady because obviously that that I find
it really hard initially and so did you
just crack on with that you'll probably
someone there just cracked on and just
did it like have you got any advice for
people early on my first client cool and
I can remember and Laura sat next to me
who is trainer furans dad yeah and I
picked up the call to Kevin linking who
is the CTO at Future Publishing and
ring-ring he answered hello Kevin
hi Kevin is Alicia Kylie sure and I put
the phone
I can remember it and I turned round its
Laura and she's went what do you do I
don't know she was like calling back I
saw I can't she was like coming back
okay and I was like hi Kevin
I didn't really mean to I tripped over
the phone and the phone the phone pulled
out anyway and just like I it was just a
blur then yes but yeah like again would
you tell people now then who when they
start yours like how do you have them
get through that because it's hard and
just like everyone is here and I've
heard it on your podcast on a few people
these are all human beings
you're here to solve a problem find
their pain solve their problem and by
solving their problem don't be an
[ __ ] don't be a dick don't be in
their face and find your really good
candidate that they need and they'll
speak to you and then build on that
relationship B D people are and I
completely get with recruitment you're
either a candidate different person a
client driven person three 6180 whatever
just go for it like what is the what I
always say dr. pepper West it can happen
that's why I always say to people like
really it's good to ask yourself that
when you often in a band chat because
it's like literally what is the worst
that can happen that find that person
put the phone down mop it for couple of
seconds but that is okay so well then
what then went on for the next couple
years and so did the things just kept on
getting better and better
yeah like Vance I grew massively like
Christian an amazing job
we had like training academy we got up
to like 70 people like yeah yeah London
like shut down and things were just
going amazingly yeah I was doing really
well I was getting booked mulberries and
the boot all things that yeah literally
living the dream we had the best time
like I was like mid-20s I was go now
we're in Clifton yeah and it like
working with my best friends who I
absolutely loved like it can connect got
better then management change senior up
technology recruitment is
I believe and again I don't know about
like engineer and I think very similar
maybe Financial Services well but tech
is completely different beast in terms
of recruitment say to like a business
support recruitment or education and we
had a new md who came in who was run sad
for years years years but was from
business support and it was a completely
different way of working and like the
KPIs that were put in place and just a
lot of things changed and we had an
amazing couple years which could not
when we left her own devices Chris was
running it he was running the show and
he was doing amazing yeah and honestly
we're making serious money for the
business yeah
and we were making great money ourselves
so was a consistent like 180 220 bitter
and yeah that and things to change
things has changed when things are
really great that I guess that's the
downside of big companies like you can
be doing great in your own little bubble
which in your from your perspective your
alarm making all this cash for the
company and then when things like things
change when you're like hangman why does
it need to change this way and those
things that it makes complete sentences
and that is a challenge when you work
for a big company isn't it yeah
and you can't like you don't have we
were only you know aim Bob no one knew
who we were
if we said brands for technology people
like huh and we're like with this
massive business but nowhere near as me
we weren't on LinkedIn we were just
doing really well
just keeping ourselves to ourselves and
it was madness and we're like we're not
sharing about a thing we're not doing
anything extra well it's just coming in
doing the job really really well not
being dicks not being ourselves just
doing what we did and it's and he's
working but we're not screaming shouting
about because we can't because we've got
a big beast of France dad looking down
on us we don't have any autonomy
there's KPIs that would ridiculous in
place and time time would time would
come since our new and then dilute
ourselves SOT done so Chris setup SR - I
already so the business was was sort of
in plan again I didn't know much about
it I'd already left
then was was contacted by Chris to say
do you want to come and come and start
it and then her sir then how long we've
been running SRT now 19 months 19 months
yes still I have no brain but before we
dive into all that like what so Billings
wise yes what's been your best year then
probably gonna be this year really yeah
which is insane because I do a million
other things and I just think how do I
still continue to build but probably I
probably on I think I'll do about 260
280 this year duper my the contract book
of about I don't even know what my con I
don't concept but maybe three grand a
week
okay yeah so I do draw desk yeah but I
did go out to contracts don't go after
contract stuff is normally from my poem
client said that need a contractor
specializing in contract because I've
always done permits what I know and I
can't do it's my network is per se okay
so let's let's talk about more recent
times then hmm so I guess let's talk
about initially I think there's a lot
there'll be a lot of people listening
that and a thinking about setting up on
their own and and I have those thoughts
and may even be in a big company like
literally probably the identical
background right so what what things
have you learned early on that like
obviously it's totally different to
being employed right so I guess what
what things have you learned early on by
being obviously a shareholder and as sr2
and it been your own business that you
can talk about there be that when you
walk in on day one and you turn on the
computer and you look at a database
which maybe if you had an old database
at a big company there's like I mean
back in the day Excel was I don't have
to go in we have no people in the day
baby the only person that was on the day
basic but on was Jordan Warren Jordan
Warren was actually we employed him a
trance dad that he was internal
recruiter at you Cass and Cheltenham
alright and we just need
I don't even know like we just don't
have a database a database is up here
and really yeah LinkedIn and our
networks and but starting a business I
mean do you know what it's the hardest
thing I've ever ever done the hardest
thing that it's challenged my my brain
hmm so differently but also challenge
myself as a person like I've had the
most up and down in terms of like not
mental health but anxiety and
expectation like I've got I come from a
very successful family really yeah who
work really hard I've got that I wasn't
good at school I got yeah I've got some
GCSEs but then I was like nah I'm out
yeah went into beauty and her dressing
as you do when you're a seventeen year
old girl and don't know what sticks when
you see a family what you mean
so my family just a great business
owners they a very successful bus and
coach company okay and which is very
well known so what what did they say
when you were going line up at that
uh-huh
go for it just don't expect me to pay
for your fame bill yeah fair enough but
they mean like I went to work when I was
fifteen
yeah I got bought my car but that was it
yeah and so the expectation but not only
from my family but for the expectation
that I put on myself and I think that
I've given out to the market being a
female business owner and okay founder
and everything that I do I've set an
expectation and I Drive myself mad
sometimes because I can't deliver the
expectation I work myself to the man
very you're very critical yourself yeah
massively oh my god I ever think AB see
everything it drives myself mad yeah
yeah so like be like prepared to go on a
rollercoaster of complete emotions that
you would never imagine hmm because you
care so
about a business and because there are
so much on the line there's a house like
Chris's house on the line and we know
won't mind me saying that but to make
the business work within our first month
of Steiner so too we sat in piccoli
knows we all went we're never going to
do this Chris you're just gonna have to
move in with really but we were only
joking it was only because of course
we're not gonna do it in our first month
but we wanted to smash it and doing fair
after we look back in in office our four
months we were like oh we've we've done
our target for the six months in three
yeah so that's and just expect a crazy
amount of emotion passion emotional
passion I think obviously if you're
going from being employed like you're
not going to start our own business and
this it's something that I mean that the
Box lots of you up ultimately doesn't
say that obviously ties into like the
standards that you have for yourself you
feel you'll feel every deal you'll feel
like we prepared to be skin as well
really 35:17 imagine six figures down to
a very small salary you do take figure
in business we're not gonna say yeah
we're all going to take the same even so
how how have you has ever been obviously
I know you you've done really well but
was there any times where you're looking
around that Chris Jerram like [ __ ] like
we're in about really bad place or like
was it all has it always been pretty
positive to be fair yeah we haven't of
course there's some months are better
than others money for one month but then
we're like well pipeline so we haven't
had that are we gonna have it yes
probably but not in like office year is
when you go right we've got a loan to
pay off because we were self-funded but
anyone else we're and so we have to pay
pay that off and that was a big focus
but yeah we have it we haven't had that
yeah so but of course we've had times
where we've hated each other and yeah
almost most of the yeah so how how do
you manage those like cuz you know I
mean like that's how have you have you
through that process have you ended up
doing the things that have really helped
those times where you're like oh my god
like mines is through the roof yeah you
know I mean have you have used there's
anything now that you do every day or
that you've learned that's how
because even when you're employed and if
you're listening and you have your own
business that's the hardest thing isn't
it'sit's ultimately it's understanding
that you are gonna have to ride these
waves it's okay to feel the things that
you are feeling but you need to get
better at managing those those emotions
right yeah especially yeah when you
employ new people in these things to
like what have you ended up doing
anything that that has really helped
yeah and like throughout definitely the
last year's my friendships have changed
quite a lot for my business because they
don't understand not outside of work
yeah I've got the most amazing us group
of friends and but sometimes they don't
get it they don't understand when
they're like me and up after work and
I'm still at work or that I'm away all
the time I'm talking at they're just
like they don't necessary again so I
haven't really had them yeah I speak
them but all they do is go you're
amazing you can keep doing this is all
positive stuff just not me but I think
yeah exactly
I am very good I've got dog cool boys
okay he's black lab he's ten and a half
point when I was 18 oh and he's amazing
he's my best friend he comes over with
me
this is really weird that I speak to him
by actually do tell him really like and
I'm like oh so what is that though is
that you gave things off your chest
yeah chest but and that's like and I'm
gonna bring him up again but with Chris
I tell him everything he knows that as
soon as I'm in a bad mood as soon as
there's something wrong like he's just
got me he's just got my brain or and
he's like just an amazing person that I
will run to him and I will go mad in a
room out of the way you just need to
release you have someone that just needs
to some people just want to write [ __ ]
down you'd like to talk the dogs yeah
two sorts of Chris and then I'm but I'm
literally fine once you get off your
chest you feel much better so anyone
that's listening if you ain't got a dog
would speak out get dog speech a war
without a speech or something
please just get it's actually getting
what you're thinking in your head and
there is something in that in terms of
feeling an actual relief of write
something down or share just showing it
about it or whatever right and get and
like I've been I've been too been
approached by men until I've been
approached by two now actually was able
to approach you what as in they want to
mentor you okay interesting yeah and
like okay what they how does that go to
their approach it was all that we do and
one of them was threesome one okay I
really okay
yes yeah and then I went to one event
and it was amazing it was such good
event and thinking about maybe doing
that but I think it's also got a lot of
people and I'd rather have one but I
went to event last week I don't know
everyone me saying I'm sure he went but
I was at an event the other day and we
all sat on different tables and this
which is diversity and inclusion up into
two in the last week yeah but this one
and I sat on the table and we had an
activity halfway through and my whole
table and we're all split up so I only
took shout it when it goes with me but
she was on different table it was all
walks alive who differently and sat down
and we did an activity and they said
okay what you'll do first inclusion and
the whole table was silent and just like
yeah okay so this is all I do
yeah and then halfway for I for Alicia
shut up because all of these people are
gonna want us to to us which is not a
bad thing which not bad thing but I'm
just like crazy busy element yeah it's a
good thing but anyway he is their head
of HR business partner for Elsevier huge
business and and he messaged me after
was like I need to speak to you and he
gone the phone to me and I had him all
ours I don't know why I demand last week
only for like couple of minutes I was
doing something yeah and he I've never
had someone speak so like amazingly
about me and I which like Oh
god he's essentially like you're the
most inspirational amazing this person
I've ever met like you are amazing and I
was too sigh all right like he feels
like he can help you yeah and it was and
I just I was just shocked I was like
what you've really want to help me he
said yeah I want to mentor you through
your life like okay that's awesome okay
let's talk about it but then yeah and
that's really cool yeah that was only
last week so there's obviously is
nothing well I think if from what the
way you'll describe and Chris and these
thing Chris is a mentor to you yeah yes
that so I think all mentors to each
other in different ways were all so
different like Chris has brought us
together and his speciality if people
really knowing the little special thing
and he's brought us together as
co-founders because he sees something
different in all of us and we worked so
well to get that really yeah that's what
makes them good recruit right okay cool
so speaking to your dog has helped yes
getting things off your chest
mmm-hmm obviously I think from day one
it seems like you've been surrounded by
some amazing amazing people so if you're
look Apes and the recruitment industry
only employ up to nine people so I think
if you are listening and you do feel
London right now because a lot of people
do right when they go set up and around
these things I think that's the thing
that I'm sure you're super grateful for
Chris and everyone around you I think
your story there is that actually share
your story or reach out to people that
can help and that is gonna be really
beneficial so I think I think it seemed
like through that process having those
people running those things have have
really helped yeah so I guess like if I
am I haven't got loads of time but if
anyone yeah like I think I think it's
interesting so I think what you're
trying to say is that you you need to
you need to say nodes you need to say
you've had to learn to say no to people
do you know I mean other are little
fingers anything wrong with that I think
I think you mentioned your friends and I
completely relates this I've got really
good friends but I think there'll be a
lot of people listen to this who are so
not their own business or recruit at the
moment and when they are saying I'm
working till 8:00 p.m. or whatever
as soon as you say the word work to
someone that doesn't quite get it mm-hmm
they initially just associated just a
lot of work in you know I mean you say
that won't work I mean it's like yeah
you know I mean and this little thing at
the end of the day it's like you've it's
done you've got a you've got a builder a
network of people friends etc that get
what do you know I mean get what you're
doing and that's why I've equipment like
you do you create amazing friendship
people that you because you're with them
for 70 hours a week Mike and you do in
all different companies they've just got
this group this campaign because you're
all in this you're all in it together
yeah so tell me a bit more about the
business thing because what I find
really interesting about you is
obviously so is it 5% that you give to
charity yes yeah why'd you do that
so SRT stands for social responsible
recruitment and like said earlier we
we've been really good at like I've been
successful in terms of equators
individually and as a group of people
doing what we do best but not shout and
about it and recruitment has got bad
name yeah
yes of course as but me personally I've
never been a dick and I've never been
when I hear stories I'm like oh my god
like how can you be like that as a human
being like how can you do it yeah and
that's all of us as well like maybe even
gross we've never been we just done the
right thing yeah just done it right and
loved our industry and loved what we do
so but we want to put people with a
profit I've always been a massive
charity person says Chris we all have
and the book came from people with
profit by Dell Partridge and it's an
amazing book and everyone should read it
but that's where the business idea came
from that we wanted to give five percent
of our profits back to underrepresented
charities in Bristol and support our
communities I've mainly always recruited
impressed so I do quite a lot in London
now um but in terms of Bristol I love
Bristol I love my city I'm born and bred
Bristol you could probably tell by the
accent mr. time
I don't do i do Joubert football but
only because latest big fall all the
time but yes if we wanted to get back to
our community and not only with five
percent of our profits but we want to
create a community driven recruitment
company and that was our mission and
always has been so it's nice to give
back like yeah like we make a lot of
money as a business recruitment is
really lucrative why not give back like
yeah yeah like CSR is aligned with you
guys is just a lie it just makes us feel
good and makes us work harder that we
know that we're giving that money just
someone they really need it and that's
awesome so yeah we've given well in
September would have been 17,000 but
really just in September alone was in
today so how many people you are now so
we are gonna be twelve on Wednesday
twelve and Wednesday yeah okay cool so I
guess so how do you know how do you sell
to recruitment now to new people that
join how do you sell recruitment to be
fed we've we haven't got anyone junior
straight out with our viewers so they've
come to us which is amazing yeah apart
from Shah and sure I took a little bit
of work she was someone who had joined
another company didn't go well and now
she's absolutely yeah and just say look
every Vikram comes not saying it's how
so I took for a wine we had a chat hmm
and then so why do you think people come
to you because we're completely
different like we are yeah but just like
we are like why we are we host and
sponsor six different meetups Markle
Eden events yeah Bristol JavaScript PHP
Southwest Bristol go line lady so UX
Bristol DevOps and cloud native I run
Bristol tech volunteers which is a
completely different set up but within
us or to run women rock we've got a
really good name in the industry now
that we fill up and
we're different in the way that like
even our culture like everything is so
chill you don't have one target you've
got your eye no target you go and do
whatever you need to do to go and hit
that really we don't care we've got a
scrum board every Monday and every
Wednesday we sit we stand up and we go
these are all candidates and then we
move them across for interview and then
we pledge and that's all we've got
there's no targets against it we have a
limited holiday we've got a financial
advisor we've got we do boot camp every
Monday lunchtime four o'clock finish one
10:30 finish a week flexible working one
two-hour lunch a week Oh loads of
benefit like we've created a culture
which is just chilled like you do
whatever and everyone does things
different in office you don't have to
stick to one thing we will support you
whenever however you want to do it
we're just go and do it the way that you
want to and if you're underachieving
we'll help you if you ever achieve and
then of course just keep going but just
do what you need to do to be successful
and hit your annual target and the
things the things about how they'll
probably be a lot of people you hear
work-life balance so much now Ryan
taxable working and all that and
tradition in recruitment that hasn't
hasn't really been the case as it so
it's like how so there'll be a lot of
people listening that that do want a bit
more autonomy and those things you know
I mean but it can be challenging to get
that within the businesses therein so
how how obviously they could go join
your company but like how can people
they have to build trust right this is
what I think they have to build trust
and then they have to say why they want
to work from home one day or whatever do
you know I mean how can how can people
what's your view on like how can people
get those types of benefits do you not I
mean because how can how can I have more
autonomy in their raw this is
challenging
I think honestly in recruitment you can
necessarily have the best work/life
balance like it's true because you need
like I'm I'm person that and it's always
been bred into me like I get in at half
7:00 I do the job boards I do 24-hour
search have seven everything come on in
like that's just what I've always done
and I will always do it okay and that's
not how I've seen success yeah
not necessary Justin that's obviously
lazy so that's my
religion knows what I do and and I think
with recruitment the more you put in the
more you get out
yeah absolutely so work-life balance
comes with experience I wouldn't let
someone do it work from home you got to
be found what you don't actually do work
from her I mean we say if you need to
work go for work from home but we don't
know in a way I mean the way it's like
this is the this is what your target is
right there in the office day we've not
won one of the founders like don't
because they prove themself they know
what they're doing and because they
respect us yeah and respect the business
and love what they do like all of them
we all love coming to work every day
well they tell you that yeah like that
goes and it's because I the girls do
come to me and speak to me a lot if
they're having a bad day with bad man
whatever
they'll speak to me like I go and I'll
just buy him like go teach them on the
way home by mateship says you're a
badass little things isn't it but they
will do love and they tell me like
they'll message me after work saying I
love you I love you too and that's like
what we do is wait if I could put it in
a jar and sell it and say this is how
we've done it although you would think
it's just I think it's like I think that
you said it from the very beginning of
this is like you Chris everyone else has
been involved like you just do the right
thing
yeah and I've sat down with a lot of
people now and you'd be surprised how
many times it does actually come down to
that is like look if you're in
recruitment for the long game
yeah like it should like beer be a good
human like do the right thing and it
will pay dividends we're not gonna be
taking over computer and good recruiters
will always be there and recruiters will
always be needed whether people shout
about us or whatever they say always be
needed so let's talk a bit about like
some tats cool stuff then so you seem
someone's quite organized do i yeah no I
am yes a lot of people ask me and they
they really like listening
so that you've been a very consistent
bill oh right and that that's difficult
to do that especially now that you're
running around business as well so I
guess how do you structure your day
let's talk a bit about that again 1/2 7
yeah again I have 7 and yeah I drop off
the dog I start my day so my day my
lesson 5 podcast if I'm like out and
about then I'll take them to my Nan's
it's a half seven 1/2 7 getting 24-hour
searches bish bash Bosh oh boy so 24 one
24-hour searches would you remember that
so updates in the last 24 hours
all right ok probably takes me about 15
minutes many minutes um go get coffee
yeah
have a shake ok I'm not I'm not Jim
freak you should be that first thing so
you're what you're looking out for is if
there's a lot of brand-new candidate
yeah on there yeah if you get hold of
them you tend to get off the job board
yeah that's right it's rare nowadays to
find a cancer on the job boys if you
don't do it then you feel like if you're
listening and you get some job or that
you have to get them off the job or I'm
off to drop by today you will get my
house and you you should work me yes you
do that yeah do that
then grab coffee and then usually go I
don't scroll through LinkedIn like home
page because I just get distracted they
just go on LinkedIn recruiter see if
I've got any messages my emails usually
up stay cuz mercury is one re mast 24/7
yeah yeah and then I just I don't know I
just get on I just do what I need to go
what you do there's more in there
everything every day you know BD source
in no really um I honestly and I don't
do be do ya know because I've got so
I've like one of you know okay big
accounts now that do take up like I
don't need to do it anymore
got amazing cancer I love like that my
best friends now like just love work for
them and their exclusive clients
candidates when you're in tech is a
candidate driven market they're not
going to be millions of candidates and
so yeah no I don't do BT none of us we
don't know how to stretch a day you just
do yeah you just do what you need to do
like we don't have to to for ourselves
time activities doing if I'm not
organizing events I'm at a meeting if
I'm doing a blog if I'm speaking there's
all different things my day is different
I could never I organized my day every
single day depending on what my diary
says yeah yeah and one of my ambassadors
for women rock is Georgia Hopkinson and
she is the agile coach ovo energy and
she our job my life a couple of weeks
ago so agile is way of working okay and
it's all about prioritizing to put in
this week this day so I'd do a day plan
every single day we might put little
boxes next to everything and once I've
done it I take off really and then say
I'm only allowed to take one thing over
until the next day
what so again oh okay oh my day plan I'm
only allowed to take one thing over so
if you didn't do free things you can
take one because that means that they're
not really important they don't really
need to do but I still keep hold of them
because just in cases like you were
supposed to send me that yeah because it
could be anything when you when you okay
funding yes I do still bill but there's
so many other things that I'm doing yeah
of course
there's not I'm not just can't at canta
canta and you don't you're not smashing
the phone anymore I'd probably make
about ten calls a week I do my
recruitment over what's up really yeah
wasn't just texting yeah clients
candidates mark on what's up I changed
my picture depending on who I'm speaking
to
yeah really see for the dog my boobs out
yeah yeah how long has it been like that
there cuz like since RJ probably like a
year actually not when you say what's
happened like you just giving them
updates oh you like trying to give
people offers on whatsapp or like what
really updates I have done and if this
is not what I do meet every single one
of my clients I don't me everything what
am I can do because London I mean
yesterday but oh sometimes won't even
speak to them I'll just do the whole
thing over text that was a Jackson if I
did that just the whole thing over text
and he only works upstairs and then when
he can does it please do and then we
just get on marijuana which is a bit
[ __ ] hell yeah that's math I know it
is but takes different techniques so
different any other industry that's how
they want to they don't want to speak
they're busy their their work in
themselves like I would much rather I
would respond someone over text and I
would have yeah I think no I think I
think you are right you got you've gotta
know what works for your market by thing
I think if you were anyone could look at
that phone and if they have a water sat
notification they're gonna [ __ ] go on
in there's no answer it let you know I
mean there's nothing more annoying than
seen that read I think you've got
respect your industry or respect your
market but ultimately I think look
what's up is huge lie on you need to be
using that light and I think there is
something about if I'm texting Alicia
and she's moral career on whatsapp
there's a I don't know the way that I'm
perceiving that is like not know that I
trust you straightaway but like I'm not
that we're mates but like it's a bit
different it's just you know I mean it's
not so corporate profession I speak to
occur at 10 o'clock like last night yes
you need to stop working your work halt
it no I'm not I do actually I'm really
good at switching area I'm really good
sleep over to go to switch now really
okay
salute a few other things before we wrap
up so you do with these meet meetups and
stuff and I think recruiters love
recruitment businesses love to do me ups
and they are really effective right so
how how can how can people like how did
you go about starting those you know I
mean any advice to run that because a
lot of people will want to do me ups and
it's a great way to generate leads and
the
a bit of a thought leader and a go-to
person in your market so how did you go
about setting these meet me up suck and
I think he came from knife so knife may
force it infrastructure at one side did
really really well but when he moved to
when he said s2 so I wonder a new market
what am I gonna do and he's a hunger do
PHP and then he started going on to the
PHP meetups and then he just said to him
one day what you want us to sponsor me
up and they were like yeah why not we
don't want you to sell and it was the
first time that ever I said I'd never
been to me like yeah and it went from
there I mean because we all then sort of
decided what markets I was doing I do a
lot of go lying Ruby Python and data
even though I should specialize in one
thing I've left job I've given Java away
I'm a good staff very late she's got
she's got my baby now but yeah I do lose
Python loads data love and go lying at
the moment so then you just because
we're in runways as well which all for
tech startups and scale ups it's like
new to me up there in space we do
obviously Bristol take volunteers me ups
and all it just sort of came about from
our markets and just could be about the
process though so before we decide right
I want to run to me I'll put sponsor me
up like I guess what main thing is IO I
view at the same you should you
shouldn't be thinking from just your
perspective as to okay how can we get
candidates and clients from yes you got
view from thinking about the people
attending and give them value right yeah
exactly yeah and I think you have to
find something that the industry is
lacking like with Bristol DevOps on me
up it like you if you signed up to it it
died to death basically and there was no
one running it so Steve just picked it
up on the stack oh my god no one's
running this I mean it's up I'm and
Steve's like the best DevOps crew ever
he's amazing and he just picked it up
because it no one had looked after it
for the last 12 months and I picked up
you've got to find something there is
really needed you can't just run
something I'm just gonna pick something
else in there and just run with it you
need to think really hard and I've had
this question a couple of times from
friends who have started up their
recruitment company going should we do
this as a meet-up our site I don't think
people are going to come so you need to
look at other me up switcher
out there why is yours going to be
different why people going to come to
yours people busy it's after work
they're tired they've got kids families
etc why is your me I'm gonna be
different and literally start with a
really good idea like we launched our
next meetup on Wednesday which is
Southwest lip and we sort by implanted
for ages and sort of got people excited
by it
is this gonna be a people go are they
hungry for this will it work and when we
started speaking to people about they're
like yeah this sounds amazing
yeah so when we got on a thing dress
really like right we're gonna launch me
yeah I think I think just add in that I
would be I would add like speech and
market yeah you know I mean why just I
think again is and I ask you this after
this but I think it is about it's just
about thinking differently when you're
having these conversations and not just
having your recruitment head on I'm
thinking because really what we're
talking about there so that's marked and
really it you know I mean so what you've
done is you when you're having these
conversations and that's probably how
she think of these ideas that I had like
these conversations over the last couple
of days and they're all talking about
there isn't enough diversity in our
market yeah why don't we try and put
something around that so it's actually
proactively and consciously speech and
market and go okay well what what
challenges are these people always
talking to me about on those things and
then actually use that information
because they're the people they're gonna
be attending anyway yeah do you know I
mean so that's myself with letters come
from it's exactly that way exactly so
it's it's this there its be smart do
your research but speak to your market
and then again have the audience of mine
don't think about it from your
perspective what you want think about
okay if people do attend what they're
gonna get out of it why would they
attend than those things okay to to
other things that I always like to talk
about and I think you do is quite well
and his personal Brandon you'll see I
talk about this a lot if I look at your
website I mean that there's a pub when
they're holding their glass of Prosecco
on your recruitment coming me to be
happy to do that so like what's your
view now I know you do a lot like course
you did on these events you're you've
got your own personal brand and you've
invested in it like what's your view on
that and like when did you start taking
that seriously I think I'm a really
weird person really yeah
my weirdness came out and I think
everyone said they used to have a book
that says Alicia says from all the
comments that came out like Alicia says
yeah and she says like is there is
Christmas Day the 25th of December in
Australia alright just love weird right
it's Mike Donald Scottish okay just
really random like just stupid things
yes and and then I was like I'm gonna
start like doing mouth shots or sending
sending clients really weird messages
that get me noticed so like one kind one
I've always liked getting with and I
still haven't now I've tried I've tried
for five years and he still messaged me
saying no Alicia sorry and I said no a
picture of a white rhino and he's and he
that's it
really yeah and I just been subject
rhino and he went and he emailed me back
and he said why you sending me a picture
of her right now I said have you ever
seen one of these before and he was like
no and I said it we can do and I went
but you don't see one of the other day
and I said and I always say to the guy
they say be unique be different like
don't worry about what other people
think like they're gonna if they if they
worry about what they think then they're
gonna be thinking about you so there's a
company in London called yo T and they
do like you know where Monza when you
set up a bank you have to do a picture
of your face and speak about it
well they do that so they do scan your
picture for identity so I was like they
had blows katanas oh I want to get this
client on like this seemed really cool
just randomly came across them and so
their pitch they're opening up their
website says take a selfie here so I
screenshotted I snap snap their thing
and just took a picture of myself like
yeah and then said put it on top of
their logo Owen said insert selfie here
and just a picture like that and I was
like so we're looking for a girl
undeveloped air I've got this guy what
do you think Google and just sent it
sent it to them and they were like
interesting wait I speak and this is my
brand why I always say
I speak to people I speak when I'm
putting things on social media to anyone
like I would speak to be offensive in
yourself anywhere else and like even
like knife no speaks is very literate
really good with English I'm awful I
mean it's awful
my Spelling's bad everything but I know
what I'm talking about that people know
what I mean like what if they're there
and I know I just say like I put peace
on the end of my LinkedIn messages I
know it's a professional network but so
what and I put hope in you I put a
picture of a giraffe the other day just
randomly like I think just I make myself
laugh I don't care about your uniqueness
it's just being yourself do not get
stuck in what other people want you to
be not like have some different if
you're in the tech industry people want
you to be different because tech is
different it's cool is unique don't
worry sue well you can I see so it
shouldn't say don't know just be like
don't worry about what other people
think so much because if you do you will
literally be the same person that says
even Mars coming in from Mars has come
in from another company he's worked in
the Lloyds London Financial Services
market he's we've landed to us then you
said to me last night show wear suit
tomorrow said don't you dare worry
really and like even if emails are so
like for more when this can't do really
good 65 brand people immediately let me
know chairs by yeah and he said good
afternoon of course but that's him being
him because that's how he's been told to
be not how who he wants to be okay so in
about and it will work and people you'll
build relationships that you wouldn't
believe
yeah and I've yeah I love that I don't
know if that means everyone listen
should start sending pictures of white
right now I think a big part of this is
that you now own your own business right
yeah so you call the shots do you not I
mean and then you you'll build in the
business that you want and I think
that's the amazing thing about personal
branding is that it's no one can take
that away from
it's legal this is who you are and I
think that is the great thing about is
that that is everyone's biggest asset
it's their network has a reputation it's
what people say behind behind closed
doors and I think great advice and I
think is from day one as quickly as you
can
although it difficult the beginning be
yourself because trying to manufacture
someone else or try and be certain
things because you think that's what
people one isn't sustainable and this
not gonna work long term do you know I
mean call it before I let you go then
what what's your view on then mindset in
recruitment oh no I think you have it
quite naturally you know I mean like
you're clearly someone that cracks on
ride the [ __ ] difficult times it
cleared him well you said you don't want
don't worry about other people's
opinions whereas that's a real problem
in today's world right there's so many
people paralyzed by people's other
people's opinions and that's really
helped some recruitment it seems like
you you sort of naturally you're just
just smashing it but like what is there
anything that other know that's helped
you go through those things that's worth
talking about quickly and I think I'm
sometimes really good at hiding it as
well already yeah like a bowling alley
yeah don't go wrong this like it's so
easy to put on a front yeah I can really
easily put on a front and there are
times where I just go like I wish I and
honestly like so many people say to me
how do you do what you do or how to do
there's like women brought you juggle
women rock you juggle there is this I
love what I do like and so all if that's
what I mean really that's what you're
saying is like you love what you do yeah
so in your head it's not work yeah no
it's not I love coming to work every day
yeah with success comes money yeah
I'm not money driven anymore that is
completely gone out the window like when
I was asking that four years ago as I
went by next I need I need more money I
need to face more people that is so gone
I'm not money driven anymore and because
you've air about other things yeah like
it that's just completely gone and we're
speaking to Christie every day so you've
just had your best ever
like and I had I did like a crazy crazy
like month I don't I speak about but and
I was like yeah it's weed you said I was
speaking to Anila previously about this
is like when I had my biggest paycheck
and recruitment I look I remember just
looking on my phone and was lying I
don't feel in the fence yeah you know I
mean this my head I know it's so way and
and because my buzz comes from other
things now my buzz comes from helping
people like women rock it's like my
biggest thing ever like my apps you love
it like if I can i it baffles me how
companies are still having diversity
problems like you could hire the most
diverse company if you really wanted to
yeah get someone who knows that there is
an amazing diversity and inclusion
consultants there's amazing recruiters
out there me they can help unlike I love
doing my raw and I'm changing women rock
to so something which is going to be
announcing and culture and but and find
something that you love about that
whether it be like if you love Aoi or if
you love machine what's helps you
throughout is you've ended art and what
I like to say to that is like not you're
not gonna like I fingers fed say correct
me if I'm wrong but you don't love every
single part your job right there's parts
that you don't enjoy doing but you had
you know you have to do I think that's
what I always say to candidates when I
was helping them through the whole
career changing stuff is like for me
it's about aiming for a job that you
love ninety percent at the time and you
are gonna have to do things that you
don't like but it's about if you're
doing a job where the only like fade
twenty five to ten percent at the time
you actually enjoy doing it it's like
you need to [ __ ] suit lie this is
real [ __ ] yeah you spend a lot of time
in work in your career you need to
change that
there's always because it's the classic
now it's like follow your passion but
it's like that isn't quite practical
it's like actually you're going to do
stuff that you don't like B need to make
sure the majority the time you're doing
things that actually you enjoying your
love and those things right so think
look I think all you're saying there is
the
and it's very clear and apparent the way
you're talking about I stuff but it's
great to see but it's like and when you
do when you do generally really enjoy a
lot of the things that you do you're not
you're not going to be stressed and I
think this you're at you're willing to
give it your all because there's
something you really enjoy right yeah
love it amen amen
love it so look and were you excited
about so you've mentioned quite a few
things but before I let you go were you
excited about in your world I am 13
February next year so I've got a list of
30 thanks Steve for 30 and one of them
was by house I bought on the 22nd
December which Mazin but I also had like
weddings buying out like the end of last
year with mental it was so much more
you'll find out okay so but they things
deep front they want to go to Australia
and one day skydive over the Parliament
by yeah I made it before and other
things I'm excited about I just see what
we can do the business like I sometimes
sit back and we all do it all for
founder's me to go we do like and I've
said it a couple eyes people do go how
you did it and I don't really know like
we just we just do it and I'm excited
tikrit I make so excited to see my
little babies my little girls not baby
it like that girls in work and the boys
of course just like flourish you just
very well like and just can't wait to
see what they do and hopefully get
another work trip in we're in Amsterdam
a couple of weeks ago and it was mental
and yeah what I'm about to launch
southwest layer hopefully go into
different areas obviously you've got a
huge account at the moment country to
see where that leads and what we can do
it and really change the culture of a
huge corporate company and taken
hopefully some control over it and yeah
and just enjoy being third I love it but
you know life awesome so yeah and why
was obviously a lot to ask before you
leave
if you could communicate to every
recruiter they'd listen to Alisha they
take on your advice they did implemented
last tomorrow could be a phrase sentence
I say my favorite quote gone it's not
gonna resonate at you know okay going to
say it now I've got to though alright
we'll say the one who's gonna say first
okay person is the secret to being a
kick-ass woman in a male-dominated
industry it's just to be really [ __ ]
good it okay and the second one is
well-behaved women rarely make history
in terms of that like end ending words
would just be just [ __ ] gonna smash it
hmm yeah nice and simple okay
awesome thank you so much an absolute
pleasure thank you thank you time